it's my first time in person also
anywhere since beginning of pandemic and
i have to admit you know i woke i was
telling sean this i woke up this morning
i was like why did i sign up to do in
person again instead of just lighting on
zoom and rolling
out but it's also like super
invigorating and exciting to do
something out of the ordinary instead of
just um you know being on zoom all day
so great to see faces in the audience
again
um okay thanks for the introduction i'm
coasted gaucho lambert again so faculty
in mechanical engineering at berkeley
not too far away
and then also really involved in our
design institute there so think of a
mirror kind of like to the d-school here
we have the jacobs design institute at
berkeley
so a quick just about me so at berkeley
i direct the co-design labs which stands
for cognition and computation and design
so we're interested in a wide range of
problems that kind of span these topics
around human behavior and design
so we run controlled experiments that we
use both behavioral and computational
methods
we also do some i would say hci adjacent
work
so we're thinking about interactive
prototypes and making new tools
typically these are things for
engineers and designers to use and then
we also study you know real designers
quote unquote in in the flesh like while
they're making so this can be both
students and
professionals i have two shameless plugs
that i'm going to do now instead of at
the end
so the first one is come join us at
berkeley no matter who you are
so i'm hiring
both
phd students and postdocs if you're a
senior phd student postdoc
we're also hiring in the mechanical
engineering department uh tenure track
position in data-driven design uh due
november 15th so if you're in this room
i presume you're interested in design
and maybe one of these two things uh
relate to you
okay
so
when i think about design right where
there's lots of topics that we're
engaged in and
you know when we talk about design
computation we might think about things
like this you know this is some photos
my friends at autodesk
this is their new generative design
platform so making new tools that
designers and engineers might use to
help realize ideas and then as we start
to move down we're thinking about
interactions and ways that people are
utilizing these tools so what makes it
helpful or useful to them
and when we think about behavior we're
thinking about people making in the
design process this can be an individual
what makes an individual creative or
successful
or we can think about teams how can we
enable teams of people to collaborate
more effectively to create better
together
so a lot of the work in my lab revolves
around studying designers and typically
you know what we're trying to do here is
better understand fundamental processes
involved in the design
involved in design behavior so
we're looking and typically doing these
controlled
experiments
and we're looking at you know some
popular focuses that we have would range
from
studying differences between experts and
novices in the design process so what
makes someone an expert at design
thinking about more nuanced topics like
different brainstorming or ideation
methods
thinking about
something i'll talk about a lot today
which is analogical reasoning and
creativity and design
and so from the title of the talk you
might have gathered that this whole
space and ecosystem that i play in
is really at the intersection of a few
different topics so we like to bring
together perspectives on human behavior
pair it with computational methods and
we're also really involved with what i
would term cognition or neural cognition
so we have collaborations with folks in
cognitive psychology and neuroscience
and i think laying at the intersection
of these different techniques we can
answer some really interesting questions
because each one of these methods really
allows us to learn something different
about design behavior
so this is a future vision of what may
be designed to look like in the future
from
some of our friends in the uk here and
i really like this vision of
kind of this future of interaction and
immersion with some of our design tools
and you can see how some of these ideas
come to life even in this quick picture
right so how we're getting these
real-time insights that might come from
cognitive processes are neural signals
that we're measuring right how someone
might have an interface and i saw that
you know you saw uh had a talk here on
uh vr and ar the other week so you know
how might someone then be you know
perceiving and getting feedback from
such an interface and actually
manipulating a real design in real time
and a whole host of questions such as
emotional response national gestures you
know emotion recognition etc
so how does this kind of thing become a
reality
so i think we have a ways to go and i'll
share some perspectives of some of the
work that we've been doing uh related to
some of these questions specifically in
the context of how to inspire people so
how to
find examples for someone automatically
based on their design work in real time
so
i call this future scalable design
support tools and we need to do a few
things right so we need to measure
people's cognition their brain activity
in some way
and start to
learn these decision making strategies
or what makes them successful we need to
monitor in some way what they're doing
whether they're
drawing on a piece of paper or they're
interacting with some sort of cad
software we need to monitor
their design concepts that they're
generating and
presumably do something with that
information and so
one idea of what to do with this
information is to give them new examples
that they haven't seen before that might
change their decision making process in
some way so if i can measure someone's
idea and maybe that's this star here
then maybe we want to reorient them in
this global space of many design
solutions maybe give them a design
that's
more sustainable or more feasible to the
one that they currently have
so i'm going to get to these topics
again but we're going to take a little
bit of a detour first
and talk about analogical reasoning in
engineering design so
the whole talk is really about finding
good examples for people
and one way to do this is through an
analogy so
whether you know this really well or
kind of
i think you'll be familiar with the idea
of how an example from another area can
really inspire you in design so
more formally
when we talk about analogical reasoning
we're talking about the process where in
information from one application the
source is applied in a new way we call
it the target so i'm trying to design a
chair i might draw inspiration from
other pieces of furniture or maybe
something in nature you know maybe a
tree inspires the new back of my chair
so we study this
more formally in the design research
community because
tons of studies and this is like the
smallest snapshot of them have
demonstrated the ability of these
analogies to help people
generate more concepts so not only more
concepts but also concepts that have
some sort of positive positive
characteristics so
maybe concepts that are more novel or
creative more feasible
and lots of open questions so um
how should we give these examples to
people right like should i give it to
them at the beginning in the middle at
the end of problem solving um
how does someone's past experience or
expertise impact the way that they might
use such a thing and then
why are these analogies helpful in the
first place you know can we actually
measure brain activity while people are
in
using these
sources of inspiration to learn about
this like mental representation of
analogies and then do a better job at
kind of answering these other sub
questions
and so here's some
common examples you might have seen
so
an example is velcro so this is a
close-up view of velcro being inspired
by these cockle bird plants that get
stuck on your pant leg and then
i love this one so this is for my
colleague leeway lynn at berkeley this
is a
small cockroach inspired robotic device
okay a couple other terms i just want to
mention off the bat so
one is this idea this notion of
analogical distance it's really
important to some of the things i'll be
talking about later on
and the difference between
a near versus far field analogy so
we'll keep it pretty simple here you can
imagine this spectrum that analogies can
fall on
a near analogy being something that
shares a lot of surface
attributes with the problem so i quickly
mentioned offhand
i'm a furniture designer making chairs
maybe other chairs
share a lot of surface level properties
with the what i want to do that would be
a near field analogy a far field analogy
is something that has mostly non-surface
level connections so a good example of
this are ones from nature
so prior work has kind of demonstrated
this idea that
there's this quote unquote sweet spot of
analogies that are most effective and
this idea is that there's not too you
know not too hot not too cold
same concept here so not too near not
too far is where it's kind of like the
optimal point of examples to present to
people
all right
so
being the you know researcher that's
curious
uh we kind of identified a one big
stumbling block here which is that it's
really really hard to even
like come up with a set of examples for
a given problem so
the first research study that i'm going
to show
is where we use a crowdsourcing
technique to actually try and generate a
really large database of analogies for
problems so we started with identifying
kind of the standardized set of problems
from the design research literature in
my community
we then crowdsourced a high volume of
people on amazon mechanical turk to
provide solutions to these problems
we then use some natural language
processing to extract common ideas and
analogies that
were helpful at these different
distances so some near and some far away
and then we tested this so we ran a
human subject study where we recruited
150 students
who were in a design engineering class
and we gave them different
analogies and we saw the impact on
problem solving
so here's the 12 problems really varying
types so we have everything from you
know design a new measuring cup for the
blind to
a device that can collect energy from
human motion
right so as i mentioned we put these
online uh we had thirteen hundred people
who solve these problems came up with
ideas to them
and what we did was we took the
solutions and we separated them into
different categories so one was really
crude based on word frequency one was
more nuanced based on
the semantic distance of the actual
content of their ideas
so then we get to kind of the fun part
is you know running these cognitive
studies with with people when we're like
giving them the the different concepts
so
we recruited 111
students in mechanical engineering
who then each got four problems and they
had 10 minutes to work on them so across
these there were different conditions
but they basically saw one condition
with common words near one with the
medium one with far and one where we're
just controlling we're giving them no
new information they're just getting
words from the problem statement
so we can see here like one problem is a
device to remove the shell
from a peanut in areas with no
electricity
and common ideas would be like crank
blade squeeze conveyor right things that
you might automatically start thinking
of when you're trying to solve that
problem
okay
so
these you know 100 plus mechanical
engineering students came up with a ton
of concepts right so we have
600 plus ideas
um and so what do we do with those ideas
so as some of you might be aware you
know it's common to to rate these
manually which is another huge burden on
poor graduate students right
so
these were rated
and this
icc is the kind of agreement of the
raiders
and so what the writers are doing is
they're assessing ideas like these that
the students came up with in the class
across four different categories so how
novel is the idea how feasible is it is
it useful
and what's its overall quality so this
kind of mega metric
okay and then this is just showing the
relationship between some of those
attributes right so with this
we see some interesting things and i'm
just kind of quickly summarizing across
what we found in this first experiment
so
one is
we see that these near examples
improve people's ability to generate
more useful and feasible concepts
and the second is that these more
abstract these distant examples
help improve their overall
novelty and so
these results
sorry these results mirror
not only what i would think is like our
intuition about the usefulness of these
concepts at a pretty high scale but also
matches some of this prior literature
that i've
alluded to in my talk
we also looked at another thing which is
you know just asking people
how useful were these
uh different
you know words for you these ideas as
you were generating problems and
uh
you know how did you perceive
the ideas in terms of this like spectrum
of you know we're trying to figure out
where our mere concepts actually near to
people and yes that you know they were
that we had this really nice effect of
near words being more near than the
medium and then the far
so that was clear to people as well
all right so this is like a it's a nice
study it was like a lot of fun doing
this crowdsourcing work
um
but it left us with a lot of questions
right like
we don't really know anything
about how people were using them why
these
uh different pieces of stimuli were
helpful for individuals and that like
opened up this whole
um
trying to answer these questions open up
this whole
like rabbit hole of work that uh myself
and my research group now we've been on
um at the intersection of design in
neuroscience and so
one experiment that i want to talk about
mirrors what i showed except now we did
this inside of a fmri so
we had a little bit of a pared down
experiment so we had just the near just
the far condition 12 problems
we had
21 people come into the lab
and solve those problems while they're
laying down inside of the mri so
i don't know if anyone here has been in
an mri but it you can imagine the
challenges that this research setup fit
poses for us
right
it's not natural
it's really difficult we can't have
people talking or drawing or anything
like that
so they're just imagining their concepts
and as you'll see in a second what we
ask people to do is each time they
thought of a new idea
they indicated that to us by pressing a
button that was
attached to their palm
so
my 30 second
fmri primer for people who might have
like no clue what this is
so
with the mri what we're trying to do is
at a high level linked tasks that are
that people are performing while they're
inside to areas of their brain that are
active while they're doing that task and
so what we do is we measure changes in
the oxygenated hemoglobin
within the brain and we're comparing
activation between different
experimental conditions conditions that
we have so
was there more brain activity so this is
like a
old sample experiment but like was there
more
brain activity while people were
watching movie compared to at rest or
doing the test so for us what does brain
activity look like
when people are coming up with solutions
with one type of example versus another
type of example
okay so
when the participants were inside of the
mri looked kind of like this
so they would get some instructions they
would see the design problems so
think of a device that allows people to
get a book that is out of their reach
they have
one minute to think of solutions
while they're given a subset of these um
you know analogies these inspirational
stimuli as we call them
and then they took a quick break 20
seconds to do a separate task that did
not relate to this brain activity or
regions that we are interested in
interested in and then they came back
they got two more
um words and they kept on solving the
problem for another one minute
and then at the end we asked them for
some rating so using that thumb pad our
keypad
they answered how useful were the words
how relevant how novel did they think
their solutions were during that
period and what was their perceived
quality of the solutions that they came
up with
and then they saw this 12 times for
those 12 different design problems
okay so what did we find
so first at just like behavioral level
just looking at the raw data
we see that participants
are generating more ideas
in the early phases of ideation so i
don't think this is particularly
surprising immediately people came in
and they just had lots of ideas right so
they see a new problem
and it's like new idea new idea new idea
so lots of ideas are being generated
early on
and then in the second half the second
one minute this you know starts to fall
off a cliff
and
the interesting thing to us is that
we see that the stimuli when they're
getting these examples that's having an
overall positive effect on how many
ideas they generate so
people generate more ideas overall in
this second period when they're getting
examples and that's more pronounced for
the near
then a little bit less for the far and
then this is the control condition
so overall the near condition is
providing uh the most help in terms of
stimuli that are generated
yes yeah for the slide before um could
you
explain why you had them do the one back
test like the unrelated
do i need tasks repeat that for the
online or is it okay i think they can
hear okay they can hear great yes good
question so
it's
in short it's not great to have you can
only measure brain activity for a
certain amount of time
before you like want those
those regions that you're interested in
to return to a baseline level
so we even the 60 second period that we
have here is like at the upper bound of
what you would want for this
um
and so in order to break that up so this
is a a problem with fmri so this is why
you might see
other neuroimaging modalities like eeg
or afners being more prevalent for this
type of work
you want to let these regions related to
critical thinking problem solving return
to baseline
so with this one back test they're like
you know just doing a finger tapping
task that's totally unrelated to problem
solving to let some of these brain
regions return to baseline and then we
measure again
really good question
okay so the takeaway on this slide was
that
more
people generate lots of ideas in the
beginning
it doesn't the the examples that we're
giving them aren't very helpful
initially
in the second kind of word set
the second one minute period
there's less ideas but we're seeing a
bigger impact of the
uh the stimuli that we're being provided
to people
okay
and so we see this if we so these graphs
are showing for like it's modeling every
instance and time across the conditions
and basically the probability that
someone would generate an idea at any
given moment
and so we see here like this outlier of
not having the inspirational stimuli in
that second problem-solving block but
like
basically all the other ones are almost
more or less indistinguishable i would
say like just to the naked eye
okay so let's look at some of the brain
activity stuff
so what we're doing here is we're
looking at the
brain activation levels that are
specifically locked around
when people are generating ideas so for
what i'm going to show here we're only
interested in like those
little windows around like when they
were clicking the button oh i thought of
a new idea
and what we're doing for this is we're
combining in one bucket both the near
and the far example
and we're comparing it at a high level
against
two times the brain activity of the
control condition so you can i'm
basically adding brain activity for near
plus far
and comparing that against directly
two times the control condition
so we're trying to see what's the
overall benefit
of any type of analogy compared to not
having one at all
love would love to talk neuroimaging
with those who are interested and we can
chat after but i just wanted to sum up
at like a high level i know this is a
broad audience
a few of the findings and like in terms
of the interpretation of what those
brain regions mean to us
and so what we saw were significant
areas of activity around brain regions
that are commonly associated
with cognitive processes such as
semantic processing so trying to make
sense of the words
and then more interesting to us this
process of directing your attention
internally so
specifically trying to recall things
from memory
um as well as
what people refer to as these aha
moments these moments of insight so
there's basically a very different
brain activation network that is present
solving a problem via insight versus
solving a problem maybe more
systematically
okay
one other result that i just want to
quickly show is more about impasse so
like
what is going on in general like what
what are people what are people doing
when they're struggling to come up with
ideas right
and so what we see is that this like
what we call the impasse network is
most present in that control condition
and we're linking this here um
in the impasse and the control condition
to there being an increase in visual
processing uh and and we believe that
this is really attributed to like people
continuing to like search for
insight inspiration but
practically
when people aren't coming up with ideas
they're just looking at the screen and
there's not a lot going on
okay
one quick uh plug here for some like
follow-on work that we did
which is using a method uh called hidden
markov models
to try and identify
like these reoccurring brain states
um that people revisit while they're
problem solving so we want to see
like do these brain activation networks
that are
kind of coordinating at the same time
are they common and reoccurring for
people
over a long period over like the entire
problem-solving set so i don't have a
lot of results here to show this is like
kind of hot off the press stuff um but
it's a really like i think fun blend
between
neuroscience a method that you might be
familiar with from another area which is
hidden markov modeling
okay so some takeaways overall from like
these
first collection of studies that i
showed
so i think overall
these results are informing behavior
during
the design process and it really
reinforces
and shows i think this direct
evidence for these common theories that
we hold so one being
that analogies or inspiration are most
beneficial to people after they've
have what's called an open goal so
basically you don't want to give
somebody
something to help them an example a
prompt
too early you want to let them work on
the problem a little bit first
have some direction and then that in
this case creativity source or
inspiration that we're giving them
is more beneficial
and the second is this evidence again of
the the sweet spot so we saw in the work
here that
what we thought were the common examples
were the most beneficial to people
but after more reflection you know
what's near to a population isn't
necessarily the most near to an
individual
so we believe that this kind of what we
thought of as the near common set is
actually a little bit shifted in on that
spectrum that i showed and more akin to
a sweet spot example
whereas the far condition that we had
was likely too far away like too
dissimilar for people to make sense of
we also were really
you know excited by and inspired by the
neuro imaging uh
element of this work
and helping to uncover these two
distinct
uh search patterns as people were
exploring the design space and so
i alluded to these but one of them was
this successful use of the inspirational
stimuli
specifically locked to periods in time
where ideas were being generated and we
referred to this as this inspired
internal search
we see directing attention to memory
having moments of insight as being kind
of these
common traits of this
one brain state and then
the unsuccessful use of stimuli are not
having stimuli at all
which is what we call impasse based
external search so basically people are
continuing to explore
their environment in search of some sort
of insight to the problem
all right
so
i want to spend my last 15 minutes or so
talking about kind of where we've been
taking some of these ideas more recently
uh and so less
relation to like cognitive science
neuroscience and the nets portion more
on
i guess design computation and design
behavior
so
the first is kind of a question that
my graduate student ananya has been
working on related to kind of a
fundamental area here which is like how
should we even
measure the similarity between things at
all so you can imagine when we're
starting to do this at scale
if i have you know a new design idea and
i want to search through some relevant
database of other design ideas so shown
here we have like lots of patents
um how should i make the comparison like
there's so many different similarity
metrics that exist to do this task
what's the best one and why
so that was like the high level role
here
so if you're a mechanical engineer you
might have seen this before this is what
we use for the experiment but this is um
basically a functional decomposition of
products so there's a
product library that has many commonly
used objects
that are all represented this way and it
you know describes uh the flow of energy
and materials through the system at a
very kind of like nice granular fashion
and we use
a whole host of methods that are kind of
described here so some are vector-based
methods
like cosine similarity uh some are
network based methods thinking about you
know graph edit distances and
uh other ones that you might be less
familiar with like the delta con
distance so we're basically exploring
these six different like commonly used
uh metrics for similarity and seeing
what's the best one
for this task of trying to find useful
examples in design
so
the core insight is as research goes
sometimes there's not really a right
answer here
but i think it's important to note that
they're returning really different stuff
so oftentimes you'll see as a and we've
experienced this in my own group
as researchers
you kind of just select whatever you
want at this stage
a lot of people select that cosine
distance metric
but we're seeing you know they're skewed
in opposite directions so having and
deciding which method here to select has
a really big impact
on what's returned and you can imagine
if you're building a system and it's
there's a user interface and people are
actually interacting with this system
and trying to retrieve stuff
uh this matters and it matters a lot and
so one of the outputs here is we started
to map
these methods
along what we believed they might be
better suited to so we're looking at
kind of complex systems to less complex
systems and better for exploring a
design space versus maybe being in a
more convergent state of exploitation
where you want to really like dive in so
that was one piece of this study more
recently what we wanted to do was see
how do all of these like algorithmic
techniques of measuring similarity
compared to
how a human if you just ask them is a
more similar to b actually relate to one
another so i won't go in depth through
this figure here because i'm looking at
the at the clock
but i think this is more useful so
basically we showed people
uh different representations of those
same products that we had initially the
functional models for and we showed them
a few different representations of those
items so in one we're showing people
like high level descriptions about like
how that design works so here's a toy
plane
and we're saying that the function is to
pump you know pressurized air into the
plane and then you know it creates
translational motion so that's one
how it works representation or level of
abstraction
and the other one is high level product
purpose so you know this nerf gun is to
export the ammo let's say right
and so we have a whole data set of like
things from water pumps to printers to
game controllers
across these two abstraction levels
and we're running a study where in one
condition
or one version we're showing people
online
different variations like this and
asking them to say
is the bike or the water pump more
similar to the plane and we're showing
them many variations of these were you
know shuffling the different
concepts
and so what we see and this is just a
quick example to illustrate how
this
level of representation really affects
you know what's returned
that
when we're looking at how a product
works so that representation
we see here you know these two items the
nerf gun and the plane were close
together because they have this shared
pneumatic mechanism that people probably
picked up on from reading the
description
but when we compare that to
product purpose
we see that the
plane and the hulk hands which is like
another toy are more similar together
because they have this like
very like and similar uh entertainment
purpose for one another so
another takeaway here going down this
like ultimate goal of providing good
examples for people is
the way that you present
the stuff really matters as well
okay
so last little section here so
way back when what kind of around the
same time as i was doing the studies for
with the neuroimaging work
we also were conducting this work where
we were
trying to give people examples like in
real time so we were letting people come
into the lab giving them a design
problem they would work on that problem
at an interval we would stop them they
would type up their solution
we would map their solution into this
design space representation
and then we would give them a near or
far example
from where they currently were within
this design space
and
everything here is based on text right
so they're describing their idea the
ideas that they're getting back are
actually the
amazon crowd
amazon mechanical turk like sourced
ideas so we're just finding like
textually similar concepts from this
large database that we have
that wasn't so good like i was kind of
underwhelmed by that and it always
bugged me that we were like using these
really simple
uh text based representations for
like this whole
process that's really dynamic in design
right like we want to let people do
whatever they want we want to let people
sketch we want to let people make stuff
in cad we want to
also support the text examples and so
this is something that two students so
alissa and forrest have been working on
which is trying to realize this vision
of like this a multi-purpose platform
that can take any type of input right
you can take it in text can take it in
sketch or 3d model and then return
something to you that's either near
or far away from what you're working on
so
i will say off front there's like we
have some really exciting stuff but i
think there's like so much room to go
and so many really really challenging
questions to explore that relate to
this topic
so
high level we're training like these two
different networks one that's focusing
on form
so we call this the appearance network
and one that's focusing on function
i won't go into the details but the
function one i think is
in particular like the harder challenge
in my opinion because it's really really
difficult
and i showed some examples of like
functional modeling but it's really hard
to know like what type of functional
representation to use
for a given problem so we can support
these two different ways searching ideas
versus that are
look like what you have and searching
ideas that behave like
what you currently have
so at stanford so i have to give you the
the plug for the data set that we that
we started out with actually before we
used partneret we tried to use a data
set called the abc data set that some of
you might have seen
which is a real abc is a really large
open source repository of
three-dimensional cad models
but there's no structure there
whatsoever so like anyone can go online
make a cad model and submit it to this
repository and there's like you know 100
000 different screws and like another
100 000 set of like
some joint so
this was nice i think for the first
approach because there was a good
structure here so
if you have seen partneret or imagenet
or anything similar there's a really
nice ontological structure where you
know we know not only like the labels
like this is a bag but the bag is then
segmented into handle and
you know fastener and all of the sub
components as well
so we have over 25 000 cad models across
24 different object categories that are
searchable within this prototype
interface that we built
and so just to give you a quick kind of
snapshot on the types of things that you
can get back so
if you're querying our system
based on this you know table
uh support based on appearance
you're getting things that you know
don't relate to tables at all
necessarily but
visually you can imagine how this like
faucet base looks like that or
for this um
dresser
how that flat component looks like a
table top or whatever else is shown
compare this to parts that are retrieved
based on function
i think more debate here
but for this the back of a chair leg we
are a back of a chair we see
you know other supports across different
chairs i like this one with the um
chair legs we see other legs but then we
see like a table support or a cabinet
support that share that same purpose of
supporting another object
okay so as i mentioned this interface
that we made supports three high-level
types of search so you can search based
on a keyword like give me a container
you can search based on another part
that you've already found within the
system so
give me you know this is the part i want
to find something that's high or low in
appearance similarity or high or low and
functional similarity
and then we also have this like
work space area where you can draw
you can drop some of the cad models into
you can expand them or manipulate the
models
and then search based on whatever that
workspace representation is
so i don't know so this is like just a
little quick video that it's like six
seconds but you can just see
you know the interface and generally
like what it looks like so this is our
first version
um
showing the different like areas where
you can enter keywords
retrieve results view something in
context see it's like sub components and
then add them into the workspace as you
as you see fit
okay
so where we're going with this
is trying to unpack different types of
search modes that are available to
people so
searching based on appearance or
function
and seeing how those decisions shape
the design space or the area that
they're covering so do people explore
more broadly in the design space when
using the
functional search or keyword search or
what have you
so
again i think a long way to go here but
this is another really nice fusion i
think between like design behavior
design computation because to enable
any of these methods right like there's
a lot of um computational work that's
underpinning this
and so uh some initial results are that
we're seeing the most coverage so people
are exploring the most the most broadly
when they can search based on the
keywords so use semantic search which
was actually i think a little bit
disappointing to see in some respects
but also there's more flexibility and
imagination that you can express in
language and oftentimes as designers
when we commit to
sketching or commit to making a cad
model we're very much more like set in
that representation or that form
okay and so just to close start to wrap
up um
i think there's
a lot of challenges and so just with
this project right we see
there's a big challenge i think with
like the data
how do we even get this like high
quality design data like it's really
taxing to do these
studies with professionals or with
students and have them come in and
make designs and relate them to one
another
so that's a huge challenge
as well as having the data in the right
form so knowing what it's about what
they were trying to do what the
intentions were there
there's also this like whole issue of
function
that
you can ask me a question about it but i
will say i don't have good insight
necessarily
but trying to learn what
something is for is like so challenging
and we like if there's any like computer
vision folks in the room like
it's just like such an immense challenge
across like any application area and we
see it in mechanical design as well
and i think you know and being at
berkeley now and being more exposed to
some of the perspectives from human
computer interaction
thinking about what an immense impact
like
the user experience and the interface
actually has on what people are doing so
you know to be quite honest this was not
like something that used to be on my
mind and now it is super present in my
mind like how do we even design an
effective interface that can serve as
this mediator between human and
data that's in the background
and so we're kind of working on now like
iterating on the interface i quickly
showed
um and starting to engage professional
designers to like use this tool to give
us their feedback
and to see how it's impacting their
processes
so
going back to the beginning right we
talked about this vision of infusion of
behavior and cognition and computation
and how they fit together to answer
interesting questions in design
and i think we're just at like
beginning to scratch the surface on like
on every single one of these like areas
behavior cognition computation
and i tried to show a kind of spectrum
of work that all shared the flavor of
how do we give find
sorry how do we find good examples for
people and how do we present that to
them
and there's
tons of other ones right that lay at
this intersection so
um
here's some nice questions if i'm
plugging you if you want to ask
something so like good sources of data
computational monitoring of design
concepts
and something that i'm really interested
in which didn't populate but like
i'm so curious about this like handoff
problem for design tools so
like when should we
like allow have a tool cue somebody that
they want to provide feedback and how
does that interaction
uh at what does it actually look like so
if you're hci person i think some of
these will look very uh common and
familiar to you
okay so i want to leave some room for
questions it looks like we have like
10-ish minutes here are some coordinates
for me so please do reach out if
i don't get to your question or you just
want to connect or if you're at berkeley
and want to come say hi
and also
if you want to talk about any of this
stuff please let me know and with that
thanks for having me and happy to take
questions
[Applause]
yes we have an online question
okay
um
thank you very much um so just for the
record of the carlos i cannot speak for
the bacon and medication perform and
my question is on uh
may have covered this a little bit more
thoroughly at the start but the idea of
disaggregating things that are already
kind of put together i'm not sure how
much you follow the regulatory space but
there's a big push on software builds up
material and trying to understand
how to basically disaggregate the quote
unquote software supply chain and it
seems that you're you're doing it an
even harder problem which is
disaggregating just broad shapes right
and i'm trying to think about where does
you fraction the different uh pieces as
they come together or not into a
particular shape and a function
um and kind of defining what you should
be thinking about it's almost like an
anthology it's a beautiful idea by the
way i was wondering if you could uh uh
comment on that uh uh conceptual nature
and if you've also thought about
kind of broader applications on kind of
like the governance side of things of
how exactly do you define where a piece
starts and the other
begins and and how they they come
together thank you
yeah really great question i i have to
admit too it's like kind of eerie in the
room here to like have the
people on zoom echoing from the from the
side um
so
to be honest that uh that was not
something that we would do we were doing
a very good job of to start and i think
running that like last steady and
building that interface really showed us
um
how we need to change our perspective so
i think we do a good job at like finding
forms that are similar but as i alluded
to in the talk
we're really struggling with the
functional side of things
and
part of that is because within our like
model that we're using
it's still
taking too much in i think i believe
from the appearance of the object and
that's not a good thing um and we also
are relying pretty heavily on the
structure of the data set that we use so
right we're not like comparing this
against
anything that exists in the world we're
comparing this against a data set that's
already been segmented into different
components so if i
have a shape that looks like a chair leg
it's going to find other chair legs and
we're going to know something about that
object's function our purpose already
it's not
you know completely open so
moving this to be completely open in the
like version that you just described is
something that we like honestly really
haven't started yet and it's going to
take a long time
i have a question um so
regarding your uh i guess the brain
imaging study you're looking at the
differences between the combined near
and far versus the control terms and i'm
wondering do you see or did you ever
look at differences between near and far
like our peoples yeah basically the
mental
uh you know cognitive structures that
people are doing activities that people
are doing from near and far
are they the same or is it yeah it seems
like the heart like basically the
further words are much harder but might
involve different types of writing or
inference or yeah yeah yeah great
question so that was our like main so
that was what we wanted to look at right
is like really at a fine grain level
understand how are these like near
concepts different from the far concepts
the truth of it is
these two processes when they're useful
are much more similar than different
and because of our experimental design
which if i was now to go back and do it
again i probably would have designed
that experiment a little bit differently
we didn't have the ability to answer
that question so we were basically not
getting any effects when i tried to when
we tried to look at you know the near
activation versus the far activation and
that's why we went for that more global
pooling effect of looking at okay what's
the effect of example versus no example
so
i don't know but i'm really curious
yeah kind of a oh there's a one here too
i don't know if
yeah um
yeah i have a question also about the
new york imaging study you introduced
earlier
and also thank you so much for your talk
um i was curious um is like any of the
differences in the results explained by
like diversity related
factors such as gender ethnicity
and or you know experience levels
because you have such a big cohort of
participants like more than 100 um for
um
for for the study
um i i assume
this is not typical for a neuroscience
uh studies so uh one uh clarification is
for the neuroimaging we only had 20
participants for the neuroimaging study
but for the crowdsourcing city right we
had
a thousand and then we it was like there
are like so many studies that we showed
so i know it's uh probably confusing but
i can still address the the question
about the
um looking at like individual
differences really based on um a variety
of factors
that wasn't something that was well
controlled for in that experiment
honestly so
there's you know obvious exclusion
criteria that range everywhere from
types of medication that people are
using to what types of glasses do they
wear like their vision
to background like we wanted people who
had a background in design
either industrial design or mechanical
design at the time
and
we didn't explicitly control for gender
like in the
uh in the paper we report say gender
differences in a variety like of other
demographic information but it wasn't
something that we were trying to control
for at that time and if i was to do the
study again i think that's another
uh thing that i would probably be more
conscious of controlling for
thank you thank you
yeah
um
what would you change about the design
if you were to go back and it's
is the reason why you couldn't have any
conclusive results on year versus far
was that because you couldn't tell if
the differences were due to
timing or like in the beginning you have
that spirit of like ideas and then
the second section was when you
introduced the part like what was the
part that you would change about
well okay i'll answer it in two ways uh
first is like my general comment that i
think
a good research project usually leaves
more questions unanswered than answered
so
there's a lot that i would now change
about the study
but to be quite honest i don't know
how much of
some of the questions i still have
are related to our experimental design
versus like the tool that we're using to
measure the data like i think you know
fmri is an incredibly powerful
brain imaging technique that gives you
really really good spatial resolution of
brain activity but it's not particularly
well suited to a really dynamic and
active task like is present in design
and so that's actually something that
we're looking at now is
like different neural imaging modalities
to test similar questions
um
but like if i was constrained to
generally the same
you know tool and task flavor and type
i would have probably like shortened
those blocks even more
to get like better signal and just focus
on like individual like ideas so let it
be flexible in time but only measure
until someone generates a concept and
then stop it have them do a different
task come back until they generate a new
concept stop it etc so
the design that we use was pretty
simplistic right like one minute set for
and then one minute again for all
participants we could have done a better
job at being more fluid there allowing
like flexible amounts of time that
varied from
i don't know 10 seconds to 25 seconds or
so
yeah
i think you had a great talk um i was
curious about
um
when you were giving far prompts um did
you see like qualitatively people using
those prompts as a springboard to come
up with their own novel ideas or did you
find that kind of their novelty was
being constrained around the words that
the forwards that you were giving them
as a prompt
yeah that's that's a good question so
i think in general like a really good
follow-on research topic that we haven't
looked at yet is like being more
explicit at linking
concepts that we're giving to
whether or not said concepts are showing
up in solutions that are being generated
and like
how the extent to which they are
uh my completely like anecdotal just you
know being a fly on the wall and
watching some of these things is that
the far examples are kind of they're
either
incredibly helpful like you just get it
you draw that connection
or it's not useful at all and ignored
and when we do this at scale across you
know 100 people or a thousand people
the the times where it was just the most
helpful thing in the world right like
i saw that cockroach and then i came up
with this like little micro robot
kind of gets washed out and the
overwhelming effect which is most people
see the cockroach example and they you
know just throw it in the trash
thanks
nice
okay maybe this will be the last
question then oh yeah in the
crowdsourcing study you mentioned a
framework that researchers were using to
objectively evaluate different
attributes of the ideas was that
framework also given to participants for
their evaluation i'm just curious if the
objective and perceived evaluation of
novelty and quality
matched up or not great question yeah no
the participants were totally blind they
were not given anything like that we
just asked them to
um
so they described the first idea that
came to mind and then um they described
the second idea that came to mind right
like with it was there was no prompt on
give me your most creative idea or give
me your most feasible idea
those were evaluation criteria that are
quite common in my field where
comparing across other research studies
you would typically want to see
ratings of novelty of quality of
usefulness of feasibility
and there's pretty systematic ways to
for human raiders to make those
evaluations
nice well let's think close up for his
great talk